now for some science news that was 13
billion years in the making
the white house has revealed the first
full-color image taken by the james webb
space telescope nasa says that the photo
is the deepest look into the universe
ever recorded taken from a million miles
from earth
the images show the earliest stars and
galaxies ever observed the telescope a
joint project between u.s canadian and
european space programs
is expected to operate for up to 20
years
it's the most powerful telescope ever to
be built
the james webb space telescope developed
by space agencies in europe the us and
canada is intended to explore the oldest
galaxies in the universe
[Music]
the new telescope is about 100 times
more sensitive than its 30-year-old
predecessor the hubble space telescope
thanks to a 25 square meter mirror and
infrared sensors it can detect galaxies
stars and planets that are hidden in the
visible spectrum by dust and gas
the telescope was under development for
more than 30 years and cost about 8.8
billion euros
thousands of engineers and hundreds of
scientists worked on its construction
more than 300 universities organizations
and companies from 14 countries were
involved
[Music]
in december the telescope was finally
launched aboard an ariana rocket
one month later it had reached its
outpost 1.5 million kilometers away
scientists hope its images will provide
insights into the early period after the
big bang
13.8 billion years ago
it will also examine the earth's
immediate surroundings in our solar
system as well as look for habitable
planets with water resources
[Music]
and
astrophysicist anthony marston joins us
he's working with the european space
agency uh thank you so much for joining
us what is special about this image
released
good morning yes uh
that's a special day we've been working
with it on this for a long time and here
we have an image
that is taking us back
after a very short length of time of
using this telescope we're able to go
back to uh some of the very earliest
things we've ever seen
what what's the point of going back
there
well it's a bit like looking at the
universe when it was a baby
uh we're trying to see therefore how you
get from a baby
to the fully matured universe that we
now live in
and in fact we have a lot of questions
about just exactly how you put together
things from
the very beginnings of the universe so
this first image uh deals with that
uh although the telescope is going to do
many other things uh besides looking
deep into the universe
so
it looks deep and it looks at things
with in detail
so
these are the two things that it really
can do
very very well tell us a little bit more
about the telescope itself and and um
you know how spectacular this is
what we're seeing now yeah
wow well the telescope itself is almost
miraculous in terms of the way that it's
been put together and
that is now functioning in space
uh
you've seen the set of hexagonal mirrors
uh that uh probably in images uh in the
past
uh
those were originally folded away when
it had to be uh it's so big it had to be
folded up to be put into the ariane
rocket the biggest rocket that barian
actually has
and
then it was deployed in space
in order to make those mirrors move to
exactly the right place within a small
fraction
of a centimeter
they had to be moved with
small actuators and
if just one of those hadn't worked you
would have had a problem with being able
to focus properly
and all of them worked
every single motion that had to be done
to move parts on this telescope in space
uh worked over a period of the first
month or so it was in space
generally speaking we don't like to put
too many moving parts into the things in
space
in case something just doesn't go
exactly as it's supposed to go
this telescope
went all out to uh to have mechanisms
that we're going to be able to move into
place in space
and that's something we haven't really
done before and they it all worked very
smoothly
incredible images which have been
released and i understand that the
mission is expected to last for up to 20
years so there's certainly more to come
astrophysicist anthony marston thank you
so much for joining us
you